et direction à présent les états unis où
joe biden doit faire face un nouveau
bras de fer diplomatique la politique du
président américain est la cible de
critiques du leader nord coréen dans un
discours kim jong-un rejette les
propositions de dialogue de washington
dans le même temps pyongyang affirme
avoir réalisé un test il y à deux jours
d'un missile hypersonique ce qui a
poussé le conseil de sécurité de l'onu a
organisé une réunion d'urgence demain on
retrouve notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas
comment les autorités américaines
j'appelle le dossier nord-coréen
eh bien il ya une très forte inquiétude
par rapport à ce test effectué en début
de semaine par pyongyang les autorités
nord-coréennes affirment avoir réalisé
avec succès un tir d'essai d'un missile
hypersonique c'est un missile avec une
vitesse plus importante que les autres
et qui le rend plus difficile à être
interceptées c'est un missile c'est une
technologie de pointe que très peu de
pays dans le monde possèdent
actuellement et c'est pour cette raison
qu'un qu'une réunion du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies a été demandé
par la france le royaume uni et les
etats unis à l'heure initialement elle
devait se tenir ce jeudi elle aura
finalement lieu demain mais cette
réunion s'inscrit dans un climat de
défiance très grand entre pyongyang et
washington puisque cette semaine kim
jong-un a critiqué très vivement
l'attitude de washington en expliquant
que les propositions de dialogue n'était
qu'une façade dit il pour masquer les
fourberies des états unis et leurs
menaces militaires contre la corée du
nord le leader nord-coréen qui semble
vouloir poursuivre sa politique en
matière d'armement tant qu'il n'y a pas
véritablement de changement de cap de la
part de washington alors le porte parole
du département d'état américain a tenté
de désamorcer en quelque sorte la
situation en réitérant les appels au
dialogue et en affirmant que les états
unis n'avaient finalement aucune
intention hostile à l'égard de la corée
du nord est puis déjà la semaine
dernière à l'onu lors de son discours
lors de l'assemblée général des nations
unis joe biden avait lui aussi a fait
avancer son souhait de faire avancer les
choses justement en vue d'une
dénucléarisation de la péninsule
coréenne le sujet de la corée du nord
est finalement un sujet assez récurrent
qui revient régulièrement sur le bureau
de joe biden également dans l'actualité
déjà au mois de mai dernier lorsque joe
biden avait reçu à la maison blanche le
président sud coréen il avait déjà parlé
de ce dossier nord-coréen écouter
s'il s'engage et je le rencontrerai s'il
y avait un engagement pour lequel nous
nous rencontrions et cet engagement
implique qui dit une discussion sur son
arsenal nucléaire et donc si c'était le
cas je ne le rencontrerait pas à moi que
mon secrétaire d'état et d'autres
personnes et négociés sur la manière de
procéder
mais force est de constater que les
choses n'avancent pas puisque pyongyang
continue de reprocher à washington et
bien les sanctions américaines contre le
pays ainsi que les exercices militaires
conjoints qui sont menées régulièrement
par séoul et washington les relations
sont en fait au point mort depuis le
mois de juin 2019 et l'échec de
l'organisation d'un sommet à l'époque
entre donald trump et kim jong-hun alors
après des premiers mois qu'on pourra
qualifier de délicats sur la scène
internationale joe biden espère
peut-être un peu plus de réussite sur le
dossier nord-coréen mais les dernières
évolutions et les dernières actualités
autour de ce dossier n'invite pas
réellement à l'optimisme pour le
locataire de la maison blanche merci
thomas bonnin en direct de washington